- [Announcer] This UCSD-TV program is
presented by University of California
Television. Like what you learn? Visit out
website or follow us on Facebook and
Twitter to keep up with the latest
programs.
♪ [music] ♪
- [Narrator] We are the paradoxical ape:
bipedal, naked, large brained. Long the
master of fire, tools, and language, but
still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is inevitable, yet filled
with optimism. We grow up slowly. We hand
down knowledge. We empathize and deceive.
We shape the future from our shared
understanding of the past. CARTA brings
together experts from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights on who we are and how
we got here. An exploration made possible
by the generosity of humans like you.
♪ [music] ♪
- [Michael] Today's talk, what I'm going
to discuss really, are properties of human
skin that support thermoregulation. Humans
have an exceptional capability to protect
against rises in body temperature, or
minimize heat storage when performing
physical work in hot environments. This
great thermoregulatory capacity probably
provides several selective advantages.
One, and these have been pointed out by
Dr. Dan Lieberman, that in early hominins
that the ability to forage safely during
peak heat times allow them to gather food
where the hunters that would use the
humans as prey, basically had to sit and
use behavioral thermoregulation because
they couldn't do muscular work in the heat
of the day. Another potential selective
advantage is that some humans may have
participated in persistence hunting. This
required them to perform at a fairly
substantial metabolic rate for extended
durations to move animals probably of
larger size and maybe herbivores for
extended periods of time until these
animals suffered high body temperatures
and succumbed from heat stroke and thus,
then became food for the hunters. So the
question really arises then, why can
humans thermoregulate in hot conditions
while foraging and hunting? Now remember,
we're talking two things, the skin for
thermoregulation, but also somehow the
skin not only dumping the heat, but also
maybe participating in the ability to
sustain exercise. So humans can do this
because they have, really from a
thermoregulatory point of view, two unique
features. The first is the ability to
regulate a steady state core temperature
during physical exertion. That's pretty
much dependent on the metabolic rate and
reasonably independent of the environment.
We won't talk much about that today. But
that's very much made possible by the
skin's capacity to support a very high
heat loss.
Now, what I've done here is I've
constructed a table that I'm going to
address in the subsequent slides, "Factors
that support high skin heat loss." If you
look on the left here, where we have the
different factors, you'll notice that four
of these obviously relate to heat
exchange, upright posture, which I'll
explain, skin blood flow, sweating and
large surface area. Now, these provide
certain advantages but on the other hand,
as I'm going to show you a little later,
they provide also problems for the body
particularly cardiovascular nature. And
there's properties of the skin or organs
within the skin that help offset these
disadvantages, such as sodium
reabsorption, and several different
reflexes which I'll talk. So, the skin can
provide large heat exchange but it also
can present problems when trying to
perform sustained work in the heat. Let's
talk first about upright posture. The
advantages of an upright posture are
fairly obvious. First of all, you have a
smaller surface area exposed for solar
radiation. As a result to that, you don't
absorb the solar radiation as much. So you
have less of environmental heat stress.
Second, and not as obvious, if you're
upright and your skin's exposed and I'm
locomoting and moving forward, I'm going
to have more air movement across my skin
than if I was haunched over. And as a
result of that, I improve both the
convective and evaporative heat capacitie,
or the abilities for heat loss. And third,
bipedal locomotion also results in lower
efficiency, so lower metabolic rate and
rate of heat production to be dissipated.
Now before I go on, I'm just going to give
some very basics of heat balance. When an
individual performs physical exercise, the
amount of heat they produce is
proportionally to how hard they exercise,
because when muscles contract, only
roughly 20% of that energy goes into
contractal shortening.
The remaining 80% is heat that needs to be
dissipated by the body. Now, I showed the
brain here because as the body stores
heat, unfortunately there's a lot of myths
that humans have selective brain cooling.
They don't. That the brain is pretty much
either similar to arterial blood pressure
or arterial blood temperature, our recent
evidence shows it might be slightly
higher, is that as body temperature
increases, we really rely on the skin for
heat loss. So that the central nervous
system acting through the sympathetic
nervous system has a proportionate
physiological thermoregulatory system
that, A, increases skin blood flow that
allows radiative and convective heat loss,
and two, increases sweating which allows,
if adequate biophysics, evaporation. Let's
first discuss active vasodilation. Humans,
compared to most species, have very highly
vascularized skin. And for you sitting in
a room at a room temperature maybe 20 some
degrees, 22 degrees, you probably have
your subcutaneous vessels constricted. So
normally, if we look over here, we have
constricted cutaneous vessels. Now, when
an individual goes into the heat, two
things occur. First of all, the skin
becomes warm, and that takes away the
constrictor effect. And second, which is
very unique to humans, at least to my
knowledge, is that you have active
cutaneous vasodilation. That sympathetic
innervation through a variety of different
pathways, cause active vasodilation of the
skin in proportion to the heat load of the
body. So, the greater the heat load, the
greater the vasodilation. And thus, then
is this warm blood moves to the surface of
the skin, if the temperature gradient is
from the skin to the ambient conditions,
we now can have convective and radiative
heat loss.
So, in this figure cartoon, we show the
impact of skin blood flow and this is
whole body skin blood flow as a function
of core temperature. What you can see is
this, if an individual is resting, you can
achieve very high skin blood flows, up to
eight liters a minute, which is extremely
high because we know in a temperate
environment, cardiac output is only about
five liters per minute sitting, average
human. With exercise, we find again that
at a given threshold, that the skin
temperature will increase but it cannot
increase as high as it can when you're
sitting at rest. And this is because of
this blood pressure problem that you have
constrictor tones so that you don't have
as high as a vasodilation. But you
probably can have skin blood flows maybe
in the range of five to six liters. Now,
the second avenue of heat loss is through
eccrine sweating, eccrine sweat glands.
Eccrine sweat glands, at least in their
number and dispersion, are fairly unique
to humans. We have about one and a half to
four million. They're located over the
entire skin. They're sympathetically
cholinergic innervated. They secrete a
very hypotonic fluid to the surface of the
skin. Obviously, as this fluid evaporates,
it then results in cooling of the
superficial areas of the skin and also the
blood within the capillaries. So, eccrine
sweat glands are different from the
apocrine glands which are often located
with hair and again, they're located over
the entire body. Now, humans can have very
high levels of sweat rate. And as a
result, if that sweats evaporate, they can
have tremendous amounts of evaporative
cooling. And this is why they can live in
environments where the ambient temperature
is higher than their skin temperature.
Here we have some data cartoon of a plot
of whole body sweat rate as a function of
exercise intensity.
As we move this way, people are running
harder, and it's going from a cool to a
hot condition. The first point I want to
make is this, we've all seen crazy numbers
in the literature about how much people
can sweat. Generally it's not unusual if
you're doing sustained hard work in the
heat to have a sweat rate of one liter per
hour, maybe a liter and a half. The
highest sweat rates that I've seen doing
thousands of experimental bodies, about a
little over two liters. People do report
in literature two and a half to three and
half liters per hour. I haven't seen them.
I assume it's possible and it's very
extreme athlete for short period of time.
But high sweat rates can be sustained in
the areas of a liter and a half. Now, when
you have these high rates of water flux,
you have to remember that the sweat comes
from the interstitial fluid which comes
from the plasma. So as you sweat, you're
going to decrease water in your plasma in
your interstitial space and your
extracellular fluid volume. So as a
result, if you're sweating and you're not
replacing fluids, your blood volume with
decrease as you dehydrate. So now, what we
see is that as an individual is exercising
in the heat for whatever purpose, of
foraging or hunting, that we have this
great capacity for heat loss, but we have
two penalties, and this is shown in a
cartoon. The first is that if we look,
what we have here, is the blood
distribution in a person standing like
myself in a cool environment. You can see
that the blood's pretty much distributed
in the thoracic area, it's easier to
return blood volume to the heart so that
you can sustain cardiac output, or how
much blood flow goes per unit time. Now,
with heat stress, you have two things that
occur first. One is you have the increase
skin blood flow. But what I also didn't
mention, if the superficial veins become
warm, they become compliant, so the blood
sits in the periphery. This means that the
blood is not in the thoracic area, it's
more difficulty to return to the heart,
reduces filling and makes it more
difficult to sustain cardiac output while
simultaneously performing exercise.
So one, the displacement. Two, that second
problem is that as I had told you, that if
you decrease your total body water and
dehydrate, the liquid portion of your
blood decreases so your plasma volume,
your blood volume reduces. All at the same
time, is when I'm standing upright, so I
have to work against gravity to perfuse
the brain, and I'm exercising and have to
perfuse skeletal muscles. So this really
causes a conundrum in terms of the human
body. Well, the skin helps to address
this. And I'm going to give several ways
that it does this. First of all, not only
do eccrine sweat glands secrete hypotonic
fluid, but they have the ability to
reabsorb sodium. That, basically you have
a reabsorption duct. So that as the sweat
comes down, that humans can reabsorb
sodium. And how much sodium they can
reabsorb depends on how well they're
acclimatized to the heat. Here's some data
that shows local sweat rate over an area
of skin, and the sodium concentration in
the secreted sweat in one, people that are
unacclimatized to the heat, people that
live in Boston in the winter time. And
people that are acclimatized in the heat,
people that live in Atlanta, where I live
currently, in the summer time. And what
you can see that obviously the higher the
sweat rate, the less efficient the active
transport is because the sodium is moving
by and you can only retake up so much. But
with acclimatization, you can greatly
reduced the amount of sodium in the sweat.
And in fact, you can basically have as
third as much...a third less sodium in the
sweat after acclimatization. So it may not
be unusual at all to see sodium in
secreted sweat on acclimatized person,
maybe 50, 60 mili-equivalents and 10
maybe, not 10, but 20 mili-equivalents.
Well, this is important because this
sodium that's reabsorbed goes back into
the interstitial, into the plasma and into
the extracellular space.
And when we look at the extracellular
fluid space, the volume in that space is
very much dependent on sodium
concentration. That's the primary cation
that's the difference between the
intracellular space. So as we absorb
sodium back into our plasma, our
extracellular sodium concentration
increases and this results in an osmotic
gradient that causes you to pull water
from inactive muscle, where water is
plentiful. So this retention of sodium
then, allows the inactive muscle to pull,
act as a reservoir. So this is a way that
you can defend your blood volume or your
plasma volume by moving water throughout
the body. So, it's very important because
at a given level of dehydration, plasma
volume would be reduced less. Now, what is
also not as obvious in, as being much more
well understood lately is that skin
provide sensory information that supports
thermoregulation. And just simplistically,
I'm going to call these cold receptors,
warm receptors, and mechanical receptors.
But through these receptors, we can sense
wetness, and we also can sense
thermocomfort, or thermal sensations. The
wetness sensation, I'm going to show you
in a minute, is very important because as
the skin is wet, that means that skin is
not evaporating that helps you basically
reduce your sweating rate so you have less
wasteful sweating to defend your body
water. And thermal sensations are
extremely important, is that A, they drive
behavioral thermoregulation, skin
temperature, skin wetness, as well as
heart rate are what drive that. And in
addition, I'm going to show you a reflex
that's probably related to the skin that's
not often appreciated that can actually
drive the core temperature to help reduce
skin blood flow requirements. Let's first
move and look at the impact of wet skin on
sweat suppression.
Here we have on the Y-axis, total body
sweating rate during minutes of exercise
where individuals are performing a given
metabolic rate of exercise over a 30
minute duration. One time, they are not
acclimatized to the heat and the other
time, they're acclimatized. During this
period of time, the investigators are
continually ramping up humidity. So, here
in the beginning, it's dry, and here at
the end, it's very humid, it keeps getting
more and more humid. First thing is that,
you can note that if humans acclimatize to
the heat, they can have a much higher
sweating rate. So you see a much higher
sweating rate in acclimatized individuals.
But second, and very important is that you
can see that as the humidity increases,
the sweating rate decreases, whether
they're unacclimatized or not. So the body
is sensing that the skin is wet, that the
sweat is not being evaporated, it's being
wasted, and as a result, I'll tune down my
wetedness. And this really can have a lot
of important implications. Here are some
old studies that were done, where they got
a large number of people and they had them
perform the same amount of physical
activity, outdoors, in a desert and a
tropic environment. So, they had the same
metabolic rates, so they had roughly the
same amounts of heat to be dissipated. But
on one condition, the tropics, the skin is
wet, and then the other condition, the
desert, the skin is dry. What you can see
that for 24 hours, sweat rates for this
population, it greatly reduced the water
requirement from about maybe five liters
down to two or three, so half the water
requirements. So, by reabsorbing sodium, I
can move water into, from reservoirs
within my body to defend blood volume, by
having skin wetedness, I can sense that
and I can reduce how much I lose and how
much I dehydrate. So, skin is very
important, then, for allowing individuals
to minimize the effects of dehydration.
Now, I don't have a good slide to show
this. If I did, I would take my 10 minutes
to explain it.
But when humans basically perform exercise
under most environmental conditions, how
high their core temperature lies is a
function of metabolic rate. And it's
pretty much independent of the
environment. But what you see, as the
environment gets warmer, and the skin gets
warmer, there is a point where the steady
state core temperature will elevate. So,
the core temperature will elevate, but
there is still sufficient biophysics that
you can just maintain that. So for some
reason, and it's been known for a long
time, that humans then will somehow pick
to have a higher core temperature at
times. And this really kind of befuddled
physiologists because back in the old
days, they used to think high core
temperature's bad, low core temperature's
good, sort of like Animal Farm, "Four legs
good, two legs bad." So what Dr. Rall,
Larry Rall from University of Washington
pointed out very elegantly is that this
actually provides an advantage. And here
I'm going to show you a table. Here we
have an individual exercising in the heat,
three different times, same metabolic
rate, same amount of evaporative heat
loss. But here we have now a core
temperature of 38, skin temperature of 34.
So we have a core-to-skin temperature
gradient of four degrees. What we see,
then, is if we do the calculations, you
would require a skin blood flow of about
two and a half liters. Now, if it got
warmer outside, and the skin temperature
went up, you have a smaller gradient and
now it requires more, because you have a
smaller gradient now from the skin to the
ambient, so you have to move more blood
through the skin to have the same amount
of heat loss to defend core temperature.
So what happens is when core temperature
actually rises up, it widens the
core-to-skin temperature gradient, and it
reduces the skin blood flow requirement
thus relieving some of the cardiovascular
stress. So in summary, I think that when
we look at the skin and how it supports
thermoregulation, we not only have to
think about heat loss, but we have to
think about the other functions that it
does that supports the cardiovascular
system.
I think we've established that skin has an
exceptional heat loss capability. That you
probably can have maximum skin blood flows
up to eight liters. That would be for a
seated person in the heat, but very
substantial. That you can have a very high
sweating rates at least in maybe the
unique Olympic athlete up to three liters
per hour, but are probably generally must
be lower in other individuals. And that
skin supports blood pressure regulation,
one, through sodium conservation, which
pulls water from the intracellular spaces
particularly in active muscle, to help
support blood volume. Two, by suppressing
the weted skin so that we don't have
wasteful sweat. All of these acting
against dehydration. And then through
thermal sensations, by one, working to
allow behavioral thermoregulation so that
the individual could titrate the work
load, or seek shade so they don't work too
hard. But also probably combined with
information from baroreceptors within the
cardiovascular system to allow the
thermoregulatory system to allow core
temperature to drift up and reduce
cardiovascular strain. Thank you.
♪ [music] ♪